the obvious negative consequence for
companies driving for sustainability is
going to be that it costs money but much
more so as also if you end up investing
in simple politically correct
comfortable answers right now it may
make make you a lot of friends right now
but later on when it becomes obvious
that this was really cheap that this was
not effective you might have a much
bigger problem so again I would suggest
that instead of doing just the easy the
simple thing let's actually look at
where you get the most bang for the buck
and do the thing that will do the most
good in the long run
if co2 is the problem it sounds like an
obvious thing to cut the carbon
emissions but the problem is we don't
burn fossil fuels for fun fossil fuels
is the backbone of our entire
civilization and so cutting it turns out
to be very expensive and often almost
impossible so instead of asking people
to do something that's very expensive or
even impossible to do namely cut carbon
emissions we should much rather be
focusing on giving them different
alternatives that are going to be
long-term cheaper for them so instead of
trying to price carbon so high that
nobody wants it that's a politically
self-defeating strategy but also it's
never going to be accepted by the
electorate we should much rather be
focusing on making solar panels
windmills and all the other green
energies so cheap that everybody will
want to buy them in incidentally that
also means that we don't just conserve
energy and switch to renewables in the
rich world where we might be able to
afford it but we can also get the
Chinese and the Indians on board
of course we should cut our carbon
emissions to the right level economists
have been looking in that and the answer
is the right level is somewhere between
five and ten maybe fifteen percent of
carbon emissions weighing the cost of
cutting extra versus the benefits of
lower temperature rises in the future is
this going to sacrifice our prosperity
no but it is going to cost us and so we
got to be careful if we cut back too
much we actually end up leaving the
world less capable of dealing with all
the problems of the world because it
will have less riches less
infrastructure less ability to tackle
those problems compared to a world where
we leave more of the global warming
problem but also many more resources to
tackle that problem
we actually emphasize we should invest
in research and development of
geoengineering because we want to know
whether it works but absolutely G R
engineering there's something we should
take into account for instance marine
cloud whitening is a very promising
approach that makes the oceanic clouds
just a tiny bit wider by putting up sea
salt into the atmosphere it simply
amplifies a natural process that means
that there's a few more particular to
which around which the clouds can
condense that makes them whiter it
reflects more sunlight and it cools off
the planet it actually turns out that 47
billion dollars in total we could
entirely eradicate the temperature rise
of the 21st century now that's about a
thousand two thousand times cheaper than
anything else we're talking about so
obviously we want to look at it but we
also need to first look at is it going
to cause other problems is there some
undiscovered problems that we need to
know about that's why we should focus
first on research and development and
then potentially as a way to postpone
the problems to give us more breathing
space to transition to clean energy we
should invest in some of the geo
engineering
in principle marine cloud whitening is a
very feasible project it would take
about two thousand ships unmanned to go
around mostly in the South Pacific Spray
up sea salt into the atmosphere have
absolutely no impact in most people's
lives although we do need to look at
weather would have impact on
precipitation patterns possibly on the
monsoon that's one of the reasons why we
need to invest in research and
development first and it would have very
very tiny effect on our economy contrary
to cutting carbon emissions it would
cost very little on the order less than
a billion dollars a year for the entire
planet